you've heard of the to sport athlete
well for John or shall those pursuits
have always been football and math
Herschel has been tackling both for his
entire life
and shattering stereotypes along the way
John Herschel may look more like an NFL
lineman than a PhD student in
mathematics but looks can be deceiving
which did you fall in love with first
math or football football certainly I
majored in aerospace engineering at Penn
State because my mother told me moms are
always right moms are always right were
you drawn to math in any way when you
were a kid I was good at math I was good
at physics I didn't particularly love it
but once I got to college I got to see
math in a pure form I would say as much
student as he was athlete in college
Herschel was already making headlines
for his unique skill set on and off the
field he finished his mathematics degree
in three years then stayed in school to
pursue two masters in the field did you
stay to get your master's because you
wanted the masters or to keep playing
football to keep playing football was it
nice for you to also break down a
stereotype of athletes don't have the
intelligence to do something like this
it was a nice side effect I've always
sort of done the things that I do
because it's what I'm passionate about
this was something that I guess came
along with it that I didn't realize at
the time what he did know was that the
NFL was calling drafted by the Baltimore
Ravens in 2014
math was benched for football I loved
football and this was one of my life's
passions I know that math is my life's
work which is why during her shalls'
second season in the NFL he found a way
to do both entering a full-time ph.d
program in mathematics PhD at MIT while
fighting the NFL is no joke do you sit
here now and think what was I thinking
what was I it wasn't a crazy crazy time
of my life but while I was playing I
don't know I felt a little you know
myself if I'm gonna be perfectly honest
because I had this dream of you know
getting my PhD in math doing good
research and I was really sort of just
letting this go and I knew I had to do
something about it
in the end math won out after three
seasons in the NFL you decide to leave
and strictly pursue math why my family I
have a little one little Joanna she's
crawling around now I came to realize
that all the things I was most excited
about in life at that point all had to
do with being a great mathematician
being a great father and doing these
things for a long number of years did
you worry about what even just three
years in the NFL and obviously the time
playing in college had done to your
brain
no I truly I truly truly believe that
I'm living my best life I wouldn't trade
my time at Penn State for the world and
I'm doing exactly what I want to be
doing I'm at MIT I'm exactly where I
want to be working with exactly who I
want to be working with and it's a great
feeling
Herschel is now in the final year of his
ph.d program with graduation and his
doctorate coming in the spring professor
John versus Baltimore Raven John which
one sounds better to you I'm really
liking the professor John right now and
the opportunity to continue breaking
down stereotypes when you walk the halls
at MIT do you see other black faces we
do not have any african-american math
professors but I'm not sure this is a my
T's fault it's not that these
universities don't want to hire African
American math professors and it's not
that babies born white in the United
States are that much better at math than
African American babies it's the sad
fact that we have brilliant young talent
in this country being born into
households where this talent is lost and
is not being cultivated what can you do
about that
hopefully setting a good example is the
first step I can't ride a bike this
could not work Herschel is also finding
a way to show off the fun side of math
the center of this wheel here always
stays at a constant height working with
the National Museum of mathematics we're
going to put the Marvel Universe under
the microscope and with Marvel Comics
taking part in a special series just as
he found his mathematical passion he's
hoping to spark one in the next
generation I try to help out with
programs that serve underrepresented
areas to show that math is truly a
beautiful beautiful thing and it's a
powerful tool in what way in that we all
make quantitative decisions every day
thousands and thousands of them mostly
without even thinking and math is truly
a language and a tool to train your
ability to think through quantitative
problems even or shalls' hobbies are a
challenge to the brain like sitting down
to play chess with friend rob Hess the
two first met when Ursel was still in
the NFL it was the opposite what I
expected because I thought I would be
like you know huge sports fan well it's
really great to meet you you know you're
both brilliant athlete and a brilliant
mathematician and he goes I've been
watching your chest videos I love your
stuff and so good to meet you the
admiration was warranted Hess is a chess
grandmaster one of only about 1500 in
the world
Herschel's aspirations are a bit more
modest he wants to become a national
master one of the best in the United
States
how far can he go with chess offer on
camera the off camera answer on camera
yes
John's very talented player and I think
his mathematical mind really helps him
and I think the competitive nature that
well he's comparing everything guys so I
think he can get really a lot better and
he's working towards that goal
I'm a master No do you think he'll reach
that goal absolutely I love the culture
here if his past is any indication you
can count on it if you have dreams if
you have goals don't shut these things
down don't fit into certain stereotypes
don't think you can't have multiple
aspirations life too short it's too
short to settle and to live someone
else's dream he's 27 lovely guy he
really is and you can see this passion
he has for math and he wants kids to
sort of be coached in something like
math the way they're coached in football
and it's developed and that love that
kids have in an athletic pursuit they
can have in these academic areas like he
did we got a lot of great sports heroes
we need some more math heroes yeah what
a great role model for young men of
color who want to be football players
and see this guy keep football up for
math right and not just football exactly
exactly